it's no exaggeration to say that marvel
is one of the most prolific and
successful entertainment companies in
the world but it hasn't always been that
way and over the years the biggest name
in comics has produced some truly
spectacular duds these are marvel's
biggest failures
in 1978 marvel was riding high off the
success of its incredible hulk tv series
the time seemed right for a whole marvel
tv universe and in another world the
doctor strange pilot movie might well
have kicked it off watching it now
however it's easy to see why that never
happened the filmmakers seemed to have
read stanley and steve ditko's classic
comics and then decided to make them as
boring as possible instead of going to a
distant himalayan sanctuary to learn the
mystic arts steven strange meets up with
some old guy who lives in new york and
rather than being the daughter of an
extra dimensional warlord his love
interest clea is just a regular old
college student even if doctor strange
had gone to series it's hard to imagine
anyone would still watch it today
everyone in this movie seems to be in a
contest to see who can have the worst
hair while strange himself wears more
gold chains than mr t unsurprisingly the
disco soundtrack hasn't aged any better
and neither have the so-called magic
effects one scene in which strange
travels to the astral plane looks like
it should have been projected on the
wall of a hippie nightclub a decade
earlier overall only one thing in the
doctor strange pilot has actually aged
well an appearance by future arrested
development icon jessica walter as the
evil morgan lafaye
good for her
adapting a marvel comic book seems like
a can't miss proposition you've got the
characters all laid out for you a
built-in audience and decades worth of
stories ripe for adaptation but the
producers of many of these movies seem
to think what fans really love about the
comics is the names because that's about
all that made it into 1979's captain
america and its follow-up death too soon
the hero is still a military vet named
steve rogers but that's where the
resemblance to the comic books comes to
an end instead of doggedly trying to
enlist to fight the fascists rogers just
wants to drive around and discover
himself and while it's never easy for a
flesh and blood actor to pull off cap's
over-the-top get-up it's hard to imagine
a faithful adaptation looking any worse
than the ridiculous outfit steve dons
for the end of the first movie and the
rest of the second no wonder they kept
it off screen so long it's also kind of
hard to get viewers excited when the
cast all sound so damn bored including
red brown as cap himself put it this way
it's not exactly the winter soldier
in 1990 the head honcho was over and
marvel pulled up their socks wiped away
their tears and gave captain america
another go and
it was terrible while the 70s tv movie
had drastically altered cap's suit this
time the project suffered from the
opposite problem director albert pion
later said i petitioned them over and
over to let me adjust the captain
america costume but they were adamant it
had to be the one in the comic what
looks good on the page doesn't look good
on the screen however and certainly not
on a budget as a result poor cap was
saddled with this wrinkly rubbery mess
bizarrely inside that suit is matt
salinger son of the famously reclusive
catcher in the rye author jd salinger
the script doesn't do him any favors
either putting him in the role of a
superhero who never actually seems to
win a fight he even loses during his
first time out in world war ii when his
enemy the red skull straps him to a
missile aimed at the white house but hey
at least cap manages to steer it to a
harmless landing in the arctic ocean
which is mostly impressive and that it
makes absolutely no sense captain
america was the work of israeli american
super shlock master menachem golin so
nonsense is par for the course this was
one of the first movies he made after
the collapse of his canon film group
given that this was how he chose to
start his new venture a 21st century
films well you can guess how long that
lasted
the fantastic four may be one of the
most beloved teams in marvel comic books
and ushered in the marvel age but they
haven't had half as much luck in the
movies in the 90s producer baron
eichenger was about to lose his rights
to the characters and he needed a quick
cheap movie to keep them from expiring
so he went to a man who knew quick and
cheap b-movie maestro roger corman the
crew didn't realize they'd signed on for
a corporate write-off though and they
took it all dead seriously despite their
efforts this is an action movie so cheap
that it goes an hour without an action
sequence and when we finally got one
it's about as underwhelming as you could
possibly imagine the human torch appears
as a sub bowling alley cgi creation and
they couldn't even make mr fantastic's
gring temples look real and then it all
ends like this unsurprisingly the movie
never got an official release but the
jokes on eischinger as he still lost all
the rights but hey it could have been
worse
it's fantastic
say that again
before samuel l jackson put on nick
fury's eye patch the role belonged to
baywatch beefcake david hasselhoff in
fact hasselhoff claims stan lee himself
called him the ultimate nick fury though
the fans apparently disagreed since his
feature-length pilot never got a full
series this makes nick fury agent of
shield a deeply strange viewing
experience it opens with armed goons
stealing the frozen body of hydra
founder baron von strucker but he's not
actually thought out until the very end
of the movie instead the plot focuses on
strucker's daughter who plans to
overthrow the world's governments with
the so-called death said virus this
forces shield to recruit their former
director who they find wailing away at a
concrete wall in a mine shaft for
reasons we may never understand there
are also some hilarious special effects
on show here including a helicarrier
that they somehow managed to make even
more comic bookie than the comic book
supported on what looked like table legs
connected to skyscraper-sized
jet engines and then there's this robot
dude who inexplicably lights up his eyes
and wide open mouth as a kind of living
movie projector to deliver strucker's
message so what did the later fury think
of all this speaking about his
preparations for the role in an
interview jackson said i watched david
hasselhoff and decided i was not going
to do any of that
the first two issues of marvel are a
broad superhero parody focused on cal
aol a visitor from the future who tries
to become a superhero but with issue
number three the story really goes off
the deep end as what little plot the
reader is given disappears completely
and the characters go on a journey to
the dawn of time apparently this all
happens so the comics writer editor bill
gemez can put his cranked up theories
about the origins of life in the mouth
of god himself as if that wasn't
self-important enough number six has cal
aol recapped the series in the form of a
sales pitch to an unseen editor who
agrees that jamaz's crackpot ideas could
bring about world peace sadly they'll
never sell because the sheeple just want
to read about superheroes beating each
other up and then like the world's worst
party guest marvel just straight up
refuses to leave this six-issue
mini-series goes on to a seventh issue
with submission guidelines for yet
another forgotten failure jamaa's
short-lived revival of epic comics how
do you sell a book like this as it turns
out the covers didn't even try instead
featuring allegedly sexy art by greg
horn of a woman who never appears in the
book getting more and more undressed as
the sales dropped lower
the writing was on the wall for marvel
imprint epic comics when it launched
with trouble the idea was sound american
comics had largely ignored the female
half of their audience since the romance
genre went out in the 80s so why not
revive it for a new generation but the
execution was doomed from day one to
appeal to teen girls editor bill jamas
tapped kick-ass writer mark miller whose
primary audience was the kind of edgy
teen boys that teen girls normally avoid
predictably he went as over the top with
the sex as he normally does with
violence leeringly chronicling the over
the top erotic lives of teenagers named
may ben mary and richard if those names
sound familiar well there's the other
problem the series was heavily hinted to
be a spider-man prequel which means
marvel expected readers to get invested
in the love life of spidey's aunt may
worse the series introduced a major
rewrite of the superheroes secret
origins that writers and fans have
wisely ignored ever since may cheats on
ben with a whole bunch of people
including richard and he and mary end up
raising little baby peter as their own
that's right spider-man's aunt is really
his mother this soap opera twist didn't
help the series much and it flopped so
hard it took almost a decade before
marvel would reprint it
the ultimate universe was the farthest
thing from a forgotten failure but 10
years into its existence this new line
of updated heroes wasn't so new and up
to date anymore the ultimate line needed
a shakeup and it got one in jeff loeb
and david finch's 2009 ultimatum
miniseries but instead of opening up new
possibilities the series closed off
existing ones killing off so many
characters that there were hardly any
left to write about ultimatum only
begins to make sense in light of the
then contemporary torture fad in horror
movies because it's kind of like a super
powered song the plot follows magneto as
he decides to wipe out humanity for good
but this is basically just a thin excuse
to kill off character after character
some of their exits are insultingly
offhanded others are so gory they're
like a parody of adult comics the wasp
gets eaten alive dr strange appears for
all of two pages to fight a bad guy who
has nothing to do with the main plot
just so we can see the sorcerer
supreme's head turn purple and explode
even when the story seems to be over
loeb adds an epilogue with little
purpose but to add cyclops and dr doom's
deaths onto the pile fans weren't
impressed of course
and ultimatum ultimately lost tens of
thousands of readers by the end of its
five issue run
not every failure is deserved however
and it's a tragic fact that many great
comic book characters and stories have
been consigned to the footnotes of
history plenty of marvel series have
come and gone over the years without
ever selling enough to sustain
themselves no matter how cleverly
written or beautifully drawn they were
and that was the fate of thor the mighty
avenger the series brought in the iconic
writer roger language to create new
adventures for thor without all the
baggage of his decades of continuity he
came back with an origin story focusing
on thor's struggle to return to asgard
and his romance with jane foster chris
samny took on art duties creating
expressive characters and inventive
designs for new versions of classic
marvel characters but even the hype of
marvel's first thor movie wasn't enough
to keep the book afloat it ended after
less than a year and the final issue
suggests the creative team had little
notice since it concludes without
answering the story's most pressing
questions tragically roger langrage
hasn't worked for marvel since
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
marvel entertainment are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one